is from Finn I match with someone on
Bumble named Kate we went on an
afternoon picnic date we've seen each
other a few times since there's only one
problem my mom's name is also Kate in
fact both are named Catherine Kate also
looks a lot like my mom almost the exact
same haircut similar facial features
dress identically and are the same
height Kate is a little older than me
and my mom is on the younger side so the
resemblance is pretty strong unlike some
I don't have interest in sleeping with
my mother do I tell her what happens if
she meets my mom do I tell my mom what I
would do is I would never say anything
try to find a nickname for this girl
that's different from what you would say
to your mom and then when she eventually
meets your mother you are shocked that
she brings up the resemblance like what
maybe I guess you do if you squint if
you see your girlfriend down and say Hey
listen I've been waiting a couple months
to tell you this you look just like my
mom I think it's gonna weird everybody
out if they have the same perfume gots
to go and that's getting a little too
much if it smells like if you finish and
you're like thanks Mom by accident
you've got to go